can you tell your story
from north korea to today as you
describe in your 2015 book
and with the extra perspective on life
love and freedom you've gained since
then
well that's a long story so i was born
in the northern part of north korea
initially
and my father was a party member
and my mom was housewife i had a one
order sister
and i remember born in the country i
never thought i was in a unusual country
now i'm thinking of what it is like
literally called the hermit kingdom
but i thought i believed that i was
living in the best country on earth
it was a socialist paradise and
everybody
in the rest of the world worshipped my
dear leader
and there was nothing to envy for me
so i had this enormous pride in my heart
and grateful to be in that country so
was love for the leader not fear
for me at least it was love yeah
it was all the moderation and gratitude
it changed lately but for me was pure
pure like love was there any
like looking back with the perspective
you have now
would you describe some of those moments
growing up
as full of happiness or was that
delusion at the time so not knowing the
alternative will you still be able to be
happy
the fact that i did not know like in
north korea this is the only country
in this 21st century has no internet
and they don't even know the existence
of internet
not only that we don't even have this 20
like like
you know 24-hour electricity so not
knowing
definitely helped i think to be sane so
as a human being
you were still able to find moments of
happiness
i think my happiness was from family
nothing else even though those they was
kept telling me that they were
our source of meaning and happiness i
don't think i ever got
happy by that maybe they're here and
they're in schools and like when i was
learning propaganda
like you know the proud feeling right i
mean the greatest nation
here and there but like actually true
happiness came from
laughing with my family and my friends
are there any childhood memories
pleasant or painful ones that stand out
do you know
i mean like you know whenever i think
about my
north korea the interesting is there's
no color
i mean one is because north korean
country has no color right most of
things are unpaved
and trees are cut down we have no fear
so people cut down trees to
make food so but only that like even
what we are wearing was like no color so
it's a interesting memory to look back
what about fashion i've noticed from
sort of
uh you now you're you're you have quite
an incredible sense of fashion
so contrast that with your time in
north korea how do you remember fashion
just or ways that people could express
themselves visually
was it all bland there was no word for
fashion in north korea
we didn't even know it was not even our
dictionary so of course i did not know
what victory a secret motors
i didn't even know what mothers were so
when i came
out i learned the more there was a job
and like what is that and i'm still
confused so
there's so many jobs that we have here
doesn't exist in north korea
what was the life like in north korea as
compared to the rest of the world so
maybe you said there's no internet
24-hour electricity is a luxury you do
not have
what about food what about water what
about basic human rights
i think that's the thing like when
people were asking me can you tell me
about
like life in north korea and in the past
i was like
i cannot describe it to you and
initially i thought
because of my english that i cannot find
the words it's not that it's a different
planet
the common sense that we have doesn't
exist there
like people literally do not know the
concept of
romantic love or human rights or liberty
so when i'm thinking back to my country
it's uh you know like as you cannot
imagine your life on mars right now
it's like that kind of difference i grew
up never seen the map of the world
i never knew that i was asian like the
regime told
me that i was kim myerson the first king
race
and then our calendar doesn't begin when
jesus christ was born
our candor begins where hymns was born
so we and history was forgotten to us
they didn't touch us about
of course christianity or like the big
bang
like our history began when kim was born
so everything was forgotten to us and
it was a different meaning i mean
feeling of existence
you know it's not even like the same
life i literally think
that was almost like my past life and
this is like a new life that i began
you're you're almost like a different
human being now absolutely
you